I'm just the key maniac I'm just
stomping through the woods with a key in
front of me Oh where's the blacksmith
why does he want to do with the black
Smithers where's the black man make him
go away
make you go away my name is markiplier
why is he using the key on the ladder
we don't know where's the blacksmith why
is he holding a ring where do I use this
ring well I use the ring I'm gonna use
this rake on the ladder
I'll take these ashes why what for
I'll use them on my first Oh daddy
please help us don't worry kids I will
venture out and take care of him
where's the blacksmith I'll kill him
he's been tormenting our blacksmith too
much I will murder your face honk give
me your key it's just a key to the
blocks move and now he's dead horse
knocked out I know he might be dead
blacksmith wherever he is if this was
the coffee house and those a general
store where would the blacksmith be I
didn't say anything
ah-ah are you serious what do you mean I
mean you clearly know more powerful
spells than that